bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat
lutter contre les déserts médicaux c'est
l'un des objectifs du gouvernement et de
la ministre de la santé et des
solidarités agnès buzyn de plus en plus
de français sont confrontés à cette
réalité territoriale la situation
s'aggrave en france les initiatives
locales elle tente de pallier le manque
dans le département des yvelines
plusieurs communes et zones sont
touchées par ce manque de médecins
généralistes alors comment faire face et
mettre fin aux déserts médicaux comment
redynamiser les territoires qui se
vident de leur professionnel de santé
faut-il attirer de nouveaux médecins
dans le département quid des maisons de
santé on en discute et en débat ce soir
avec en plateau docteur michel villiers
moriamez vous êtes médecin généraliste à
guyancourt et membre de l'association
am3 et l'amicale des médecins des trois
villages vous êtes avec cette
association à l'origine de la première
maison médicale de garde de montigny le
bretonneux et joséphine coleman ce
berger vous êtes maire de plaisir et
première vice-présidente de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir à tous
les deux bienvenue sur ce plateau les
histoires de carvi libre mais lorsqu'on
regarde un petit peu les statistiques il
ya comme un léger paradoxe
la france n'a jamais compté autant de
médecins plus de 200000 praticien a
recensé en début de cette année 2010 est
et pourtant les déserts médicaux
persistent et s'étendent eux mêmes dans
les zones dans les grandes zones
urbaines alors où est l'erreur quel est
le problème le problème est complexe
une partie de l'explication vient des
années où le numerus clausus a été
extrêmement bas et il est aujourd'hui
remonter énormément on peut pas lui leur
remontée plus on risque de mettre les
hôpitaux et les universités en
difficulté donc il ya eu toutes ses
années de numerus clausus bas il ya la
féminisation de la profession il ya le
fait que les générations actuelles ne
veulent plus travailler de la même façon
que travaillaient les anciennes
générations avec des journées de 12
heures et des et des carrières
extrêmement lourdes est donc aussi bien
les jeunes hommes que les jeunes femmes
ne veulent plus ce type d'exercice
il y a aussi des éléments qui sont liées
à la façon dont les français prennent en
charge leur santé aujourd'hui ils la
prennent en charge de mieux en mieux il
ya un vieillissement de la population
avec de plus en plus de maladies
chroniques par rapport à mon exercice
mois ya 30 ans quand je me suis installé
où la demande de soins était une demande
de soins curatifs proche maintenant dans
l'immense majorité des cas ce sont des
prises en charge au long cours de
maladies lourdes de maladies complexes
et pour lesquels il faut revoir les gens
régulièrement avec des suivis et tout
cet exercice là est très différent sel
sont des consultations beaucoup plus
compliquée à mener pour le médecin qui
lui prennent plus de temps et dans
lesquels la prévention aussi a pris une
place très importante donc pour moi
c'est tous ces ensembles là qui font que
notre système de santé est en crise et
qui va falloir apprendre tous ensemble à
le faire évoluer pour
meilleurs soins de la population
joséphine coleman berger un système de
santé en crise la ville de plaisir fait
face depuis quelques mois
deux médecins généralistes ça vous
semble inédit c'était prévisible selon
vous
oui c'était certainement prévisible mais
pas de façon aussi rapide on s'est rendu
compte qu'il ya plusieurs éléments et je
rejoins docteur quand il évoque toute
une série d'éléments qui véritablement
impact cette problématique mais il est
clair aussi que il y a il y à un
phénomène qui est un phénomène
vieillissant bien sûr des médecins aussi
fait oui il ya le papy-boom aussi où la
même boom et puis aussi cette preuve
cette problématique qui est pas une
problématique en soi mais c'est de
mettre aux normes tous les locaux où
sont installés les médecins et par
exemple sur plaisir où nous avions
énormément de maisons médicales privées
et bien depuis quelques années avec la
nouvelle loi qui passait sur l'adapt
l'adapei il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui et
bien des propriétaires privés ou même
des médecins eux mêmes ne souhaitent pas
ou ne peuvent pas dans le contexte
réhabiliter tous ces espaces mettre aux
normes pour répondre justement à ces
nouvelles maladies chroniques a
forcément forcément pour l'accessibilité
handicap puisque aujourd'hui vous savez
que tous les bâtiments doivent être
remis aux normes que ce soit les
bâtiments publics mais également les
bâtiments privés qui accueillent du
public donc on se retrouve dans une
vraie problématique est non seulement et
je vous rejoins quand vous dites docteur
qu il va falloir s'adapter ou que la
société s'adapte mais la population aux
signes devra malheureusement je dirais
s'adapter à un autre mode de
fonctionnement on avait l'habitude je
vous donne un exemple à plaisir dans les
années 90 nous avions plus de 24
médecins généralistes aujourd'hui nous
n'avons plus qu'une dizaine
donc cette proximité attendu par la
patiente elle est complexe parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut presque pas
encore imaginer qu'on puisse faire
quelques kilomètres pour aller chez un
médecin ça nous paraît complètement
aberrant et comment est-ce qu'on
comment est-ce qu'on accueille comment
est-ce qu'on
attire de nouveaux médecins dans les
communes
alors la première chose moi je suis
aussi en seniors la faculté responsable
du recrutement de maîtres de stage la
première chose c'est de favoriser
d'améliorer ce recrutement dans la
nouvelle formation des médecins
généralistes ils auront un an de
formation en médecine générale
+1 premier stage lors des premières
années lorsqu'ils sont externes grâce à
ça la proche de la médecine générale et
la qualité de la formation des futurs
généralistes va être bien bien meilleure
et je pense que s'il ya
dans des zones rurales pourquoi pas un
des uns des messages les plus importants
à mon avis c'est par rapport aux
collègues et par rapport à tous les
patients potentiels d'aller voir leur
médecin comment vous n'êtes pas maître
de stage qu'est ce qui se passe parce
que si le médecin devient même de stage
es20 peut-être que quand il arrêtera son
activité parce qu'il sera usées et qui
ici sera l'âge de partir peut-être que
quelqu'un prendra la relève
là aujourd'hui nos pistes de recrutement
c'est des jeunes qui sortent de la
faculté et qui reste en contact avec
nous et qui commence à former les jeunes
avec nous redevenons tuteur et c est
aussi des plus âgées à qui on vend ce
message ne restez pas seul vous êtes
débordé c'est vrai vous ne serez pas
plus en ayant un jeune qui en plus va
vous redonner de la joie d'exercer un et
donc on dise maison donne ce message à
nos étudiants donnent ce message aux
patients allez demander à votre médecin
de se former pour devenir maître de
stage il n'a pas du tout la fibre
enseignants ok mais autrement c'est une
chance pour lui est une chance pour les
patients que des on voit par exemple une
ville comme trappe qui est une ville qui
a subi exactement la même chute
démographique que plaisir et que tout
les toutes les communes de la vie
nouvelle parce que tous les médecins
soient installés en même temps ils sont
tous en moyenne 57 58 ans et bien sûr
cette commune il ya une maison médicale
en formation il ya quatre jeunes
médecins qui sont en train de
s'installer et de former un pôle avec
des paramédicaux grâce à cette à cette
maison médicale plus rythmé sonel il va
y avoir une solution il va y avoir des
partage de tâches il va y avoir du coût
des tâches que les médecins vont pouvoir
déléguer à l'infirmière il va y avoir du
coup du temps médecin qui va être
restaurée parce qu'il y aura moins de
temps administratif pour le médecin
c'est pas la solution c'est un élément
qui peut permettre que des les jeunes
médecins il réclame beaucoup de travail
et dans ce style de structures pour
avoir du temps libre pour avoir du temps
en famille pour pouvoir prendre des
congés et donc c'est un effort qui est
en cours sur la ville nouvelle
puisqu'il y a eu ça cela serait pareil
choix en place à préserver tout à fait
c'est à dire que notre rôle en tant qu
il lui s'est déjà d'enlever ce côté
anxiogène de la population ce sont
vraiment les premières demandes
aujourd'hui que nous avons en tant que
maire
les uns et les autres un sur mes bras
mme le maire que faites vous que faites
vous eh bien on essaye de faire des
choses mais on n'a pas tout en main on
n'a pas la capacité je dirais en tant
que médecin sur plaisir on à la création
aujourd'hui d'une maison médicale qui se
met en place qui est privé la ville a
mis à la disposition de ses médecins un
terrain en centre-ville véritablement
pour pouvoir créer cela est actuellement
après trois réunions avec des médecins
et des pharmaciens également parce qu'on
a voulu les mettre dans la boucle parce
qu'ils sont impactés aussi par ça on a
souhaité parler de ce fameux projet est
un projet de maison médicalisée comme
vous évoquiez docteur sur le fait d'un
projet puisque vous savez que le
département aujourd'hui accompagne ce
projet de façon plus que conséquent
puisqu'il accompagne l'investissement de
façon globale et aussi le fonctionnement
en mettant en place julien cet
accompagnement à ce que vous évoquiez
sur l'administratif qui si lourd pour
les médecins avec que les secrets d'un
secrétariat bien sûr pour les rendez
vous mais aussi pour accompagner sur
administratif il nous faut deux médecins
pour démarrer cette maison médicalisée
c'est une condition sinequanone dont un
médecin généraliste est actuellement
suite aux trois réunions que j'ai faite
j'espère véritablement avoir un retour
pour lancer ce projet sur plaisir
puisque
voilà on se bat tous ensemble oui il ya
plusieurs se battre tous enfants
justement il ya plusieurs maisons
médicales qui se sont ouvertes dans le
département est-ce qu'on peut mutualiser
les efforts pour justement répondre de
manière globale en tout cas sur le
territoire yves hinant il ya déjà des
depuis des années il ya une fédération
des maisons et des pôles de santé depuis
des années il y à un partenariat avec la
rs grâce à ça des maisons qui se créent
et qui respectent un certain nombre de
leurs agences régionales de santé et qui
grâce à sa vont permettre que des
professionnels se regroupent qu'il
recrée une offre de soins et notamment
de soins de proximité qu'ils soient pas
à trois semaines un mois 1
et à partir de là il ya des financements
pour la coordination de ces structures
qui obligatoirement coûte un peu plus
cher qu'un cabinet libéral où nous on
fait tout quoi qu'on chante nous
entourent nouvelle le matériel où on
s'occupe de tout par nous mêmes et donc
là bon il va y avoir des structures
différentes et avec en plus le fait
d'être dans un même lieu de travail de
partager des temps de concertation
autour du patient 1 ça c'est très
important pour avoir des rémunérations
spécifique de l' agence régionale de
santé il va falloir qu'elle est réunion
pluriprofessionnelle où on va partir des
cas qui nous pose problème à plusieurs
et où on va du coup apprendre à se
connaître apprendre à travailler
ensemble déléguer des tâches et être
plus au service du patient alors très
rapidement il reste deux minutes
d'émission joséphine coleman berger
j'aimerais selon vous l'avenir bonds est
aux jeunes et aux futurs médecins
diplômés comment leur transmettre cette
envie d'exercer
s'installer dans ces zones qui sont
aujourd'hui désertés par la profession
comme alors de l'angle de rester en
prison oui mais en préambule c'est de
dire que quand on est allé les
rencontrer parce que je suis venu les
rencontrer ici on nous a dit je te
disais le docteur précédemment c'est que
leur leur vie comme ils l'envisagent
dans les années qui viennent et pas du
tout la même que celle précédemment donc
ils veulent ils souhaitent autre chose
et je crois que le partenariat avec les
élus le partenariat avec ses maisons
médicalisées pour montrer qu'à
l'intérieur on va y travailler
différemment qu'il va y avoir ces
collaborations que vous évoquez c'est à
nous de faire passer le message bien sûr
aux professionnels aux enseignants qui
sont à l'université mais aussi à nous
les élus pour dire qu'on est là aussi
pour accompagner les maisons
médicalisées et aussi un accompagnement
par exemple avec les promoteurs les
promoteurs sur plaisir moi je leur
demande expressément de prévoir des
cellules pour accueillir des médecins en
bas d'immeuble et c'est quelque chose
que j'impose pratiquement pour justement
leur apporter tout tout ce confort là je
crois qu'on doit travailler beaucoup
plus en collaboration ça a été a
remontré privé très ferme et peut-être
un moment donné et pas du tout en lien
avec nous les élus mais on est là il
faut absolument qu'ils le que vous le
sachiez voilà mais je crois vous le
saviez vous docteur docteur michel
évidemment rien mais juste un mois je
crois qu'il faut que et c'est une de nos
responsabilités donner envie aux jeunes
de ce2 de s'installer qu'il découvre et
qu'ils voient que cet exercice est
extrêmement riche et est très gratifiant
et qu'on peut tout à fait gagner
correctement sa vie et que l'on peut
être très heureux en étant médecin
généraliste merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à ces missions fin du
set 8 débat ce soir consacrée aux
déserts médicaux l'émission est à revoir
sur notre site internet et a commenté
sur les réseaux sociaux bonne soirée à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]